I've never seen it like it I did this  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  Kjell over here what the hell how could  this many people be infected the city is  completely cut off isolated don't look  at me like that all right I'm not  unaffected but right now it's got a  hard-on for the only two stars left in  town they don't need a bleeding heart  like you getting in my way  stars office has to be in this direction  gets worse every night  they don't want the world to know what  they've done it's wrong with umbrella  stop alone you gotta get out you guys  are the ones who cause oh come on  we've gotta be dreaming  commitment honesty integrity these are  the core values that create the  foundation for umbrella core  for the players